♫
>> Tucker: WE HAVE TALKED A
LOT ON THIS SHOW AND WE ARE
GOING TO TALK A LOT MORE
ABOUT THE GROWTH OF THE
POWER OF BIG TECH COMPANIES
AND HOW THEY ARE NOW A FAR
BIGGER THREAT TO YOUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES THAN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EVER WAS.
NOW THE HEAD OF A SOCIAL
MEDIA NETWORK SAYS THAT
GOOGLE IS CENSORING HIS
COMPANY.
HOW?
BILL 00MAN IS THE CO-CREATOR
OF MIND.COM AND HE JOINS US
IN THE STUDIO.COM.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: GOOGLE IS TRYING
TO CENSOR YOUR COMPANY, HOW.
>> WE GOT BANNED FROM
ADVERTISING PLATFORM
PROBABLY CAUGHT UP IN THEIR
OUT-OF-CONTROL ALGORITHMS
WHICH BASICALLY BAN
COMPANIES WITH KEY WORDS
WITH NO RATIONALITY.
>> Tucker: NOT OVERSTATING
IT SAYING IF YOU ARE BANNED
FROM GOOGLE’S AD PLATFORM IT
CAN BE DEATH FOR A COMPANY.
>> IT CAN.
IT HAS ACTUALLY KILLED TONS
OF COUNTRIES AND CONTENT ON
YOUTUBE DEMONETIZED PRETTY
SERIOUS.
>> Tucker: THEY HAVE THE
POWER TO SNUFF OUT A YOUNG
COMPANY.
WHY DID THEY DO THIS TO YOU,
DO YOU THINK?
DID YOU DO SOMETHING WRONG?
>> PROBABLY SOME KEY WORD
THAT GOT CAUGHT UP IN
ALGORITHMS BUT IT’S ACTUALLY
A SYMPTOM OF A BIG HER
PROBLEM OF CENSORSHIP
ALGORITHM HAPPENING ON ALL
OF THE MAJOR NETWORKS.
WE ARE ACTUALLY BUILDING OUR
OWN AD NETWORK TO BATTLE
THIS AND COMPLETELY
TRANSPARENT ON THE BLOCK
CHAIN SO THAT EVERYONE CAN
SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
OUR SYSTEM.
COMPLETELY OPEN SOURCED.
ANYONE CAN EXPECT IT, PIER
REVIEW IT THIS IS HOW THINGS
HAVE TO BE.
IT CAN’T BE PROPRIETARY.
>> Tucker: CAN’T.
ONE THING THE NEWS CONSUMING
PUBLIC DOESN’T UNDERSTAND
ALMOST ALL NEWS YOU READ
ONLINE IS CONTROLLED BY
GOOGLE OR FACEBOOK BECAUSE
THEY CONTROL 90% OF THE ADS.
THEY ARE IN CHARGE.
THEY OWN ALL THE NEWS
SOURCES IN EFFECT.
>> AND WHEN YOU GO TO
PEOPLE’S WEBSITES WHO HOST
GOOGLE IS SPYING ON YOU
THROUGH THOSE WEBSITES.
BY PUTTING GOOGLE ADS ON
WEBSITE YOU ARE BECOMING AN
AGENT OF GOOGLE.
THAT’S WHY WE NEED
TRANSPARENT, MORE FREEDOM
BASED AD PLATFORMS TO EMERGE
WHICH DON’T SPY ON PEOPLE BY
DEFAULT.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE
CHALLENGING ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLETE MONOPOLIES IN
AMERICAN LIFE.
WHY WOULD THEY LET YOU DO
THAT?
>> IT’S NOT ABOUT THEM
LETTING US DO THAT
DECENTRALIZATION.
OPEN SOURCED.
BLOCK CHAIN, TRANSPARENT
SOCIAL NETWORKS ARE EMERGING
AND THERE IS REALLY NOTHING
THEY CAN DO ABOUT IT
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL
TRANSFORM.
THAT’S WHAT YOU CAN HOPE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU THINK THAT
THEY HAVE THIS POWER, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
NOTHING ABOUT IT THEY HAVE A
MONOPOLY BASICALLY OVER ALL
DIGITAL INFORMATION.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REFUSES TO REIGN IT IN FOR
WHATEVER REASON.
YOU THINK YOU COULD PROVIDE
AN ALTERNATIVE TO THAT.
YOU CAN FREE UP THE SYSTEM
FROM THEIR CONTROL.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, IT’S HAPPENING, FREE
OPEN SOURCED, DECENTRALIZED
NETWORKS ARE RISING UP.
>> Tucker: WHAT’S IT GOING
TO BE CALLED?
>> I MEAN, IT’S GOING TO BE
A NETWORK OF NETWORKS.
NEXT BIG NETWORK IS PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO BE A
CENTRALIZED SITE.
IT’S GOING TO BE MULL
TUESDAY OF NETWORKS
INTEROPERATING SO IT CAN’T
GET CENSORED.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK THIS
WILL RADICALLY DISEMPOWER
GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK.
>> I THINK THIS MOVE WILL
FOR SURE.
>> Tucker: HIRE BODY GUARDS.
JUST KIDDING.
GOD SPEED.
WE WILL BE ROOTING FOR YOU.